who's the girl her name is Jess for
she's our intern you're hitting that I'm
right here no Farhad I'm not hitting I
should hit that yeah hi still right here
in Venice gang a really long time I had
what I needed and then the girl walked
in I know you're doing something big I
want in maybe you could teach me in your
room that is so bad is it does it feel
sexy on your face it does okay let's go
Kahn you mean know why we make so much
money we are retired receivers a science
to getting people to trust you do we
have a deal yes we have a deal
you know this is really fun it's all
about emotion in connection what makes
you think you can trust her there's no
room for heart in this game they don't
get you killed
I wouldn't trust him if I were you but I
should trust you you got a problem I am
going to kill you kill me later but it
would be nothing you lost everyone's
money - Wow without
I cannot believe you lied to you can't
believe I lied Campo gets so rich from
those what you want to say because
you're always lying me and now we're
dead
at the end of the day this is a game of
focus it's very confusing isn't it
that's what you get when you hire a con
Oh